welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
turning to Gopal with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we begin with this the
impeachment hearings that begin this
morning mark just the fourth time in
history that Congress has considered
removing a president from office think
about that the last time was 1998 when
the House of Representatives impeach
President Bill Clinton so let's go back
to Nancy Cordes she's at the site of
this morning's hearing Nancy how would
you compare the current inquiry to the
last one well Toni the partisan divide
is certainly similar with President
Clinton Republicans had the majority in
the House and they were moving forward
with an impeachment inquiry into a
Democrat in the White House and just
like today the minority party argued
that the majority had been trying to
take a president down for years I did
not have sexual relations with that
woman miss Lewinsky President Bill
Clinton lied under oath about his affair
with a White House intern triggering an
impeachment inquiry in the
republican-led house then like now the
parties were split over whether the
president's actions represented what the
Constitution refers to as high crimes
and misdemeanors California Democrats
O'Laughlin he lied about sex not an
admirable thing but really not an
activity that shook the foundations of
the Constitution and the democracy
Wisconsin Republican Jim Sensenbrenner
the President of the United States
should be held to the highest standard
of anybody in the country both lawmakers
sit on the House Judiciary Committee
which handles impeachment they were
there in 1998 to what stands out to you
about that time it was a heck of a lot
of work the Judiciary Committee got all
the stars evidence dumped on us we're
the few days notice in this case there
is no special prosecutor like Kenneth
Starr to gather all that evidence my
role today is to discuss our referral
and the underlying investigation so the
Intelligence Committee has been
investigating instead with a series of
closed-door depositions this is
a joyful experience for anyone engaged
in it but it's an obligation that we
have given the facts that have been
discovered so far
President Clinton famously said the
process was beyond his control
president Trump has mounted a more
direct defense we had a totally
appropriate I even say perfect
conversation in the end the House voted
to impeach President Clinton on two
charges but he was acquitted by the
Senate less than two months later with
some Republicans crossing party lines
William Jefferson Clinton be and he
hereby is acquitted of the charges in
the set articles Sensenbrenner predicts
acquittal for president Trump to the
president is not going to be removed
from office I think everybody realizes
that the split here in Congress is
reflective of the divide in the country
according to the latest CBS News poll
53% of Americans approve of the inquiry
into President Trump while 47%
disapprove not that far off from 1998
when 53% of Americans said they would be
satisfied if no action were taken
against President Clinton and the entire
matter were dropped
Anthony yep and those hearings begin in
just a couple hours Nancy thank you